oh he's coming down on the left hand
side if dribbling it goes between his
legs
dunks balls like oh my gosh you hear the
saying like you changed like you're damn
right of course I've changed I'm trying
to better myself why haven't you changed
I want to be the greatest of all time
and that's just mom I said what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have LeBron James level talent adds
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the meant to me
seriously try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little bit more
time with them some of their beliefs
mindsets way of thinking way of seeing
the world seep into us to help us become
the best version of ourselves so today
we're gonna learn from one of the best
LeBron James and how to do the
impossible
mentor me LeBron
[Music]
let's kick it off with rule number one
be the chosen one but I first heard
about this young kid from Akron we were
looking for the next big basketball
superstar magazines newspapers internet
Sports Illustrated had him on the cover
as the chosen one so I took a bunch of
my key executives down to his game run
all my Nike guys down this is the time
they shine all of a sudden he's coming
downs on the left hand side he's
dribbling it goes between his legs
the ball is like all my gosh everybody
in the whole arena went mad was crazy by
the time he was a senior everybody in
the country you know every day you gotta
go out there and work because there's
someone out there working to and if you
stop I think they can bash you
rule number two maximize your potential
one thing about myself I'm real critical
in myself I believe I can't improve
unless I want to improve and Ultima I
want to become the greatest basketball
player or the best parent LeBron James
can be now if that means I've become
better than Michael Jordan or better
than Kobe Bryant or Oscar Robinson then
so be it but if not I want to maximize
my potential so the times are with my
rookie year where I was struggling I
found the way to get through it myself
with the help of friends and you know
not having those yes-man around me
because I was a player for me I
understand that a lot gets thrown upon
my plate and like gets thrown upon what
I do so for me my personal goals is to
win championships and at the end of my
career where I was able to accomplish
will make me happy and make me satisfy
because I don't play for I don't play
for what people expect for me to do
anymore
I want to be the greatest of all time
and that's just my mindset wherever they
laid me at the end of my career you know
if this no one nine twelve or whatever
the case might be Smitty I had a great
time playing this game vertical rule
number three persevere no you're here to
saying like you changed like you're damn
right
of course I've changed I'm trying to
better myself why haven't you changed
and that's and things that you have to
deal with even as a kid growing up
playing ball you you look back and even
go like Muhammad Ali and the things that
he had to go through they basically told
him you're the heavyweight champion in
the world but you have your beliefs and
your religion no we don't care about
that we're gonna strip you and since you
don't want to go to army and fight for
us then we're gonna see you to jail for
three years like and that's it without
question and when you are want to want
to think outside the box people don't
know how to take it
dr. Martin Luther King is another prime
example a guy who put his life on the
line every single day for the betterment
of life itself and in our small world us
as basketball players but us as
african-americans we still feel to hate
all decisions we make that we feel like
it's best for us and because people
can't make the decision for you the only
thing they can do is to begin a rally of
hate and we have to go through rule
number four just give your all
as well as we play last game and ain't
gonna be enough to win a knife you got
to get more dog you gotta protect more
you got to help more you gotta sacrifice
more in order to get this win
well my expectation is always gonna be
out because half the lives individual
like I continue to get better every year
I continue to bust my butt off see to
get ready for a season is going to junk
food so I look forward us competing for
a championship this year and every night
I go on the court I approach it that way
that's China to get better for a long
time girl short trying to girl we want
to just continue to get better every
night I'll set out a goal two years when
I came back to bring a championship to
the city
I gave everything that I had I put my
heart my blood my sweat my tears to this
David
against all odds against all odds I
don't know why we want to take the
hardest road I don't know why the man
above gives me the hardest role but
there's nothing a bit man above don't
put you in situations that you can't
handle and I just kept that same
positive attitude like instead of saying
why me but saying this is what do you
want me to do over there at the table
have been around the sleeve a long time
and they just said at the end of this
ball game that this is your greatest
achievement
finals okay we've been counting up for a
long time this season and
No write it right around the trade
deadline no matter we made a trade or
not at that point time I kind of just
switched my mindset all Santas let's get
the most out of this season I can and
I'm determined to get
but most I'm trying to squeeze this
horse there's no more juice left in town
this is a heck of an accomplishment for
our ballclub
you know without all-star power forward
as well for basically two games
this team was undefeated in the
postseason of home impossible
for me to be able to lead these guys as
a treat and rule number five the last
one before a very special bonus clip do
the impossible
2011 he's up against Dallas and NBA
Finals so much pressures on LeBron
everybody's expecting him to win and he
loses in six games he was devastated the
media really killed this guy but what
did LeBron do the very next year he gave
you his third MVP trophy his first
Finals MVP and his first ring
you see those things and you wonder this
human
[Applause]
you failed the way that he feels when
the whole world is watching and this
inspiration to see this guy really come
back and do it the way he did what makes
him great on that level is the fact that
he's able to do the impossible he
inspires myself and many that you can do
anything that you put your mind to
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from LeBron on how to know your worth
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that I want to know from you
which message resonated more with you
from today's clip maximize your
potential or persevere vote down in the
comments below looking forward to
hearing from you thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
being unlike a first generational money
maker in the household is a scary thing
and for 18 year old I go from being
sitting in classrooms and may graduating
high school to being a multimeter near a
month later for me it was like holy now
we're in this Roman is real it's not
like I had that moment we were sitting
in that room at Reebok and Paul fireman
was very smart he said to you you know I
know you're gonna go see Nike and Adidas
but I'm gonna offer you ten million
dollars today if you don't go see them
and shake my hand
he offered he brought you a ten million
dollar check in that room and you turned
it down I can't say I would have turned
to done I mean I think in the room I
said yeah let's take this check and get
the hell out of here but you turned it
down was it see what was that thinking
with you do you remember what I was
thinking of why you did it well I mean I
remember first of all the one of the
longest damp tables adversely my longest
table but the longest ballroom tables
I've ever seen in my life and I had no
idea what he was doing at the other end
of the table I just seen him right yeah
and he was talking his head down he was
making sure he didn't get anything wrong
on it on that check and when he slid it
down there and he said listen if you
take this right now you know you just
promise me you won't go talk to Nike or
adidas you know you can take this right
now and and I was I was lost for words
at the beginning I mean if we flew in
I flew in from Akron Ohio this spring
here a new project on the projects I
mean I written is like 17 dollars a
month but now I'm looking at a 10
million dollar check that you can leave
with it yeah and go to high school and
go back to the classroom and the next
day I was you were going to homeroom the
next one was going a whole room the next
morning so I'm like holy Sh
that's my first initial thing and then I
for some odd reason I started thinking
like if this guy which is a he's a great
guy to still love him to this day
unbelievable God but if he's willing to
give me a ten million dollar check right
now what does this say that Nike or
adidas is not willing to give me
or 30 you know upfront you know or to
say that maybe the upfront money is not
even the biggest thing you know maybe
let's start thinking about the backing
in you know and you know I've always you
know in that comes from you know my
uncles as well just you know never put
all your eggs in one basket you know and
give give it an opportunity to give
people an opportunity to say what they
what they got to pitch themselves and
you know we all we always say that I
said we're gonna hear all three
companies we want to hear all three
companies what they have to say
you know what's they're playing and I
can't I still can't believe I left at
ten I can't believe it if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it you
act like I am Tulsa what a wail out of
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I'm murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access